my journey actually started with 0.12
for 0.13 in react and
then came 0.14 and everything was
awesome like a lot of react it was
awesome it was doing exactly what I
needed and wanted it was a UI Library
not a framework TM and then 15 came
along and that was a bit weird
um at this point the first warning signs
um but on the other hand the they wrote
this blog post that was like really
really long it was long long so I
thought like either this is dedication
while a lot of guilt
um but I don't care either way is fine
for me as long as they're committed I
run with it so it continued and
oh God it takes a while
um so I went with 15 16 17 18 and I'm
still on react
so far so good
the and especially what I like about it
is
so I wasn't concerned because what I
like about it is every time I ran into a
problem there was a lot of information
on the official talks to twitter.com you
could always find information on Dance
profile on Sebastian's profile Andrew
and so on and so on it was it's just
fantastic and it's for real you know
this is probably like a little bit
seriousness
um so for example do you know that
flashing from react Dom you can actually
Force to flush everything so in this
example uh you can actually update your
messages in the chat and then scroll to
the last one this works you don't you
don't need an effect for it it's
fantastic I actually missed that one
someone in the workshop told me about it
why did I miss it because it was on
YouTube it was tweeted on YouTube but I
don't watch all the YouTube videos that
they are tweeting so sometimes you miss
it but get in the workshop was pointed
out and but then another one
um as for example did you know if you
have a small component or application
that in this case uh there's a sum
component which has a key on which we
can change on every button click and
the thing is that if you change the key
so for example from ABC
to J ghi it's really it's remounting the
component the whole thing it's it's not
in an array in not in a map in a list or
so it's really really cool
um where did I learn it exactly Twitter
there's no mention of that in the talks
oh no but if you look at the last line
it's awesome they're actually changing
this
they really make it better so initially
I didn't want to talk about it but have
you checked out the beta docs they're
awesome and I didn't want to mention it
because like yeah I don't want to spoil
anything but I mean if you Google for it
it's the first entry in Google so I'm
fine to share I hope
and yeah
um at this point you might wonder you're
in the state charts track what is he
talking about
um but on the other I think you're too
deep in and like getting up out is
probably too weird now so uh enjoy the
ride
let's talk about composition so we're
gonna jump around between different
topics at this point
um composition so the ones that are
really long around
um
uh know about this we have mixins in the
past this was this was
somewhat terrible that was actually
terrible we had two-way data binding you
know we come from sort of angular times
and you couldn't have a framework that
didn't have two-way data binding so of
course react had it as well
and we had memo before memo pure render
mixing fantastic
um but then yeah this came out another
blog post and you realize well maybe not
the best idea and at this point for like
maybe I'm part of an experiment I'm not
sure it was a bit odd
um yeah
but anyway you know same as you're in
this talk now I was I was too deep into
it and I just went along the right and
then came higher order components and I
was on the hype train love the idea I
was I was so fascinated but it was the
first time I heard about closures and
functional programming and so on it was
fantastic
um
and then in the end when you build large
applications it was horrible it's like
unmaintainable so we basically figured
out we shouldn't do this and if you look
at the recompose
um uh repository nowadays yeah they
basically say don't don't just don't do
it um so we get rid of all the high
water components well not completely but
almost
um and yeah and then came the the one
thing that I really hated from the
beginning
um I really did and I never said it
loudly because you know you can't move
against the community
um but random props oh boy they're
nesting here it was Steep and deep and
deep and deep and and you even had like
people did render props when you didn't
pass it in any random props because just
it was the feeling and this was also the
time
um when I started using like this
colored parenthesis because I couldn't
stand it anymore so in the end I would
say we tried everything we really tried
and we ended up with folks and I would
say we can't be happy we we found
something it works we it's pretty good
um and yeah I'm I'm actually glad that I
I went along the ride and learned a lot
about it because maybe I would uh
challenge it at this point but
um I think hooks are are actually really
interesting except when you talk to
friends who are back in the engineers or
so and then you start to explain them
that we have stateful functions uh at
this point and
um yeah they're really really cool
except you can't put them in a loop or
in a conditional but apart from that
year it's awesome and they're like what
um
but you're already so emotionally and
like energized that you just continue on
it and yeah because the they actually
helped us to get rid of non-extendable
classes
um which was the thing back then and
like what
um yeah and then you just continue in
emotions and you tell them about jsx we
write our templates right into our
business logic and yeah then you lost a
friend
um yeah but it was great
um so let me jump to the complete
different topic again
um I love my name to exports there was
this time I could do all my react
components in which named exports and it
was great the the auto completion was
was fantastic I loved everything about
it and then came very crazy and I was
like oh God why are you doing this to me
so basically if you wanna use recklessly
you have to have
um the component exported as a different
I was like no why are you doing this
um and yeah I just was frustrated and
you know you try to you're working with
a team and you try to come up with
conventions you're saying like Okay
we're only going to use name exports but
for react components we use default
exports and everything gets confusing
except uh very recently and I haven't
even tried it yet learned that you can
actually use the name to export it looks
clunky but I'm gonna go back to an index
but if this works I think it does
um except again using
next remix
they require you for all that is their
pages and routes to do named default uh
exports again so yeah maybe I give up I
don't know
um
anyway happens
um but the
big question would be already talking
about next here that I see nowadays
coming up now and then
um and I really hope someone asks me
this soon uh is should I go for react on
xjs
and I really really hope someone does
because
if this happens to me I'm gonna be like
this
and then go for it so well so react has
graphql that's really really awesome to
use next only has rest plus plus apis
but it also serves the rendering so it's
a tough choice what do you think
um yeah I hope this happened soon
um and
that's a cannot play next I mean this is
the landing page they really they really
make it obvious uh that they have ever
react framework I mean come on this is
this is one of the biggest headlines
I've ever seen you cannot
um make it bigger
all right let's jump to the next topic
typescript
so we have react types fantastic a lot
of typescript I love typing
um it really really helps me to to stay
sane so uh basically with react types
um you should do this so you have
component for example and you have
react.function component and
um yeah well maybe not you could also do
FC as an alternative
so I really enjoy when there's multiple
options
I also thinking about the JavaScript
proposal that they have fun function
funky as declarations for function names
but yeah I have to open the stage zero
still let's see and then you learn
that actually a lot of people that are
consider typescript experts they all
tell you like don't use it at all what
why we have react types if we shouldn't
use it at all
so they are basically saying well it's
bad mostly this is like the most common
argument
um you have this implicit children so
that the children you can to any
component you can pass them in or not
and react or a typescript will not
complain at all
and basically saying like yeah you do
this instead because then your children
are not implicit and you have to
explicitly declare
um that if a component takes children or
expects children then you should pass it
in
I was like okay
um well fine enough let's move the whole
code base away from react FC we do this
and we are good
and then whenever you onboard someone
and they have like they're just learning
typescript or so
um they basically ask it why why is this
when they discover the reactive C thing
and they're asking you why and you're
like well let's talk about something
else
um yeah
and then then came the the Savior this
pull request I was so so so excited when
I saw it the first time so with react
eating types the immediate breaking
changed they sneaked it in
um because nothing in react regarding
that change but the it's a good chance
to to do it
um so they get rid of the implicit
children but bam
um so what does this mean basically if
I'm having
um a component that accepts children I
have to explicitly clear now that these
are children if I'm expecting it I can
still make it optional but like this
this is uh there's a reason behind it
because if you're doing this types from
typescript will not complain will be
happy awesome awesome but the component
expects children so if you don't pass
them in typescript will tell you hey
there's something wrong here
um and this exactly fits my mental model
of what I'm expecting of a type system
you know I took this Wikipedia declare
um uh description uh it basically tells
the aim is to prevent operations
expecting a certain kind of value from
being used with values which that
operation does not make sense yes it
should make sense everything awesome
awesome
um yeah and also the other way around if
I'm just leaving out the children
because I'm expecting there's a
component where I don't expect any
children not doing anything with it I
basically when I have this here and if
someone is using my component this way
they should get a typescript error or
warning or whatever
and so I was really really happy wow we
could finally use react FC
um and then the best part they even
offered a cold mod so I don't know if
who has heard of a code mod raise your
hands
okay half of two people so code mod is
basically like uh tooling CLI tooling
that you can run over a cool base and
will fix your code base and basically
fix all the braking changes so what does
it do in in this case
um so there's multiple changes that they
had in this one types upgrade code mod
it basically
um fixes your your components with like
react
um so it does this generics of generics
and yeah in the end basically
um it should fix things
and
what they're doing with this is the
adding back children because here
there's like props with children so I
was like wait a second in my grieving
component which is not using children
what do you mean
so I looked into props with Children
what does it do
and then I felt like have you learned
nothing
they are optional children in there like
all these complaints and we're going
back to this are you kidding me
um so like what is going on I was like
this
yeah
but
on the other hand I didn't contribute I
never said anything
so I can only complain well that's what
it is
um but I have one suggestion maybe for
the next breaking change
how about we do this props with optional
children
would make things slightly better and
what I can do now is I can use react FC
and I can
um not use props with children at all
I've banned it from the code base you
will yeah I wish I could do if you open
a PR then then I would just write back
you should think harder but I would
probably just write you an essay of like
why this is the case but yeah anyway
let's move on next topic
um
warnings warning so awesome
uh react is really doing a great job
performance so
um I guess who knows this warning like
you ever you have a state updates uh
exactly yeah so you're all not cleaning
up your effects here right
um
but that's another topic we come to that
later
um so this is It's kind of okay nice so
quiche yeah
um it tells you at least what's going on
and and if you have time you can look
into it and fix it I mean it's happening
mostly on only anyway uh now and then
but the thing is it's only good if you
have control of it
if it's coming from a package it's
really really annoying and I want to
show you this like this is for real this
is my day-to-day when I start coding
um
this is my console log from
as a react native app with with react
native web and then there's like just
two components in there that just don't
comply to some warnings and you and
seconds to go down and find my first
debug statement it's really annoying
um
yeah so I was I was like oh God why can
I not get rid of this and then I also
recently learned that you can patch
console log
and okay the adult thing would have been
to like now go into an into the app and
and fix this and and filter out the
console log and Patch it
um
but no I felt like this is awesome for
pranks
um so
um
take this this is really really good
um so what what is it doing basically I
I show it to you I copy paste it here
um so yeah I can't log it you have to
hide it in your code somewhere sneak it
into a PR bit the larger the part the
the better chances that you're not get
detected and basically when you then
enter a console log
it will get hidden at the end it right
now it's 702 milliseconds I don't wanna
like I really wanna have numbers that
are not easy to find
um and the thing is yeah you can see the
guy with the mouse is really annoyed
um
I know this is a bit off topic but I
think it's really important there's no
prank chairs so I have to put it
somewhere here
um but and I think that there there's a
lot of notion that we can put into it so
if you want to collaborate let me know
um so I think like the the right time is
so when it's like shorter content it
should disappear in a shorter time I
mean it's larger content so you wanna
you're able to find the sweet spot where
it's annoying but they are not actually
starting to look into it
um yeah good pranking and of course
don't make it easy for them they should
not find anything in your code base if
they're looking for console for Locker
for clear this is really I I put some
effort into this so so make good use of
it
um yeah but back to my real problem
um
I I really wanted to put it in a lip and
then open source it and publish it and
so on but preparing a talk is a lot of
work so maybe next time
um
yeah
I would definitely get rid of this
problem
um all right by the way I did report one
of them the other one I couldn't
reproduce in an isolated setup
um also one is already fixed but the
release is not working for us because
dependency is complicated
um but the other one yeah I will just
patch whatever
so
um getting to the last big topic
[Music]
question who of you is using strict mode
who of you has an idea what strict mode
is
half the hands okay
um really so strict mode is this thing
that you can wrap your app around and
basically it gives you warnings
um wait a second race again who views
using Street mode
why okay okay just kidding
um
uh well so strict mode is really really
annoying so
um
uh
basically if it's too annoying just
disable it
um I'm just getting but well maybe
seriously well so what does it actually
do
um there's this list on the react docs
not not the twitter.com but really the
react.org
um and basically they have this list and
explanations
um mostly so the first four are just
about like Legacy warnings
um that are annoying
um and to be honest if you take care of
your dependencies uh you probably I mean
these are really outdated apis uh so I
haven't seen them in in months or years
maybe
um but the last two are interesting
because they they came in fact 18.
um and they say detecting unexpected
side effects and ensuring reusable state
so what I did doing is basically they
making sure that when you start your
application they render everything twice
they run every effect twice they
basically do everything twice
and it gets really really annoying it
has a purpose oh but by the way only if
you have strict mode and only if you are
in development mode so yes that means if
you're in development mode and have
strict mode your app will behave
differently basically than in production
it's completely fine
um
yeah but the thing is so it has this
purpose that they basically start
cleaning up your effects you should do
the proper cleanup
um
and the purpose of it that basically
wanna in the future pre-render your
components uh so they can have like
better user experience or take your your
stuff off screen from Dom and then put
it back
it has a good purpose they they're
moving with this in in some kind of
Direction
but the thing is if you like
just get
a friend of mine like
they he spent a day figuring this out
that it renders twice the black uh areas
yeah they're swear words that are to
comment out and basically there's no
hint no information nothing if you're in
that situation in your browser and you
you get to that state where it's like
why is it rendering twice why is my
effect running twice there's no no info
at all and I was like come on we have
constant lock for everything we have
warnings for every little bit and this
one we don't and people yeah the people
don't get it you really don't need to
point them to a link and and show them
like this is what's happening
and so in the in the good old uh fashion
of like oh the good old times of react
conferences I'm happy to announce react
reduced stress
so what does it do well by the way this
is like half serious but it actually
works so so I I put a lot of love into
it
um for one evening
um but so you can yarn install it it's
really on npm and yarn and and so on uh
you can start your app then you go to
your your uh editor of choice and you
can import it it's a default export
sorry I'm just still used to it
um
see you you input reduce stress and you
put it inside your strict mode so next
to your app you can actually put it
anywhere
um except it like it really has to put
in in the strip mode
um and what it will do is this probably
should go into the record but I will
create an issue and see if they like
this
um it gives you a warning hint
you are in strict mode attention your
thing will render twice and it gives you
a link to go to to read more and to
understand what's actually going on
um yeah uh so this is react reduce
stress but let me explain a bit about
the background
it comes with uh smds never heard about
it well it's the strict mode detection
system
um I found it in the react code so in
their tests how they how they how did
they figure out the strict mode is on
they basically catching console logs
surprise surprise there
um so uh yeah and I hope the react
Corpus is still the core classes if not
I say it was called pilot and artificial
intelligence doesn't uh
um have any license license issues so
awesome the law is just the law is just
better than react in any way it's
awesome and I I really did it dark mode
support so the the red is a has a slight
notion in in dark mode
um so yeah a lot of effort and of course
we
only supporting modern browsers Firefox
Chrome Brave Edge uh yeah and we don't
support
electricity browsers like Internet
Explorer Safari obviously
um yeah so to come to an end because the
next Peak you want to come along uh
there's a lot more that I could talk
about that really we have to stop this
now
um
with all these cultures in react
um it was a fantastic ride I mean I'm
doing this three reactions years
um and I learned a lot on the way and I
I'm sticking around for a foreseeable
future because it's still it's still my
framework of choice especially for
Native and so on like I can do things
that I could never imagine a couple
years ago and and
even reflecting I felt a bit like an I
was part of an experiment learning all a
lot of weird things
um I still learned a lot and I I really
enjoyed the ride
and so I kind of I kind of continue
um and complain of course
um yeah
and but to have some conclusion for you
as well not only for me
um learn Have Fun and Profit so read the
beta docs they're really really really
good they're not complete but there's a
lot of like good examples uh sneak in a
console Lord prank please
um and install react reduce stress
and finally you're getting to your stage
charts thank you very much I hope it was
a pleasure